so it's my great honor
to welcome our keynote speaker professor
marilyn goose so marilyn is currently
professor in the school of education at
the university of queensland and she's
recently become head of school as well
she's been in maths education for 25
years
as a teacher as a researcher and as a
teacher educator so in every possible
capacity
and now as an administrator as well the
project coordinator
her research has been guided by
sociocultural theories of learning she's
investigated mathematical thinking
analyzed pedagogical issues in how to
introduce educational technology into
mathematics teaching and learning she
studied how communities of practice are
established and maintained in the
secondary mathematics classrooms and as
well as in context like we have today
the communities that we have present in
this room and hope to build in teacher
education contexts
she's president of mergan for those of
you who are younger and don't know what
that stands for merker is the
mathematics education research group of
australasia they run conferences have a
journal and she's also editor-in-chief
of
another highly prestigious international
research journal called educational
studies in mathematics
she's a lead author of the textbook was
here a moment ago
which we use here at sydney university
teaching secondary school mathematics
research and practice for the 21st
century so
we can't think of a more appropriate
person to give today's keynote address
please welcome marylanders
thank you so much
thank you so much for inviting me to
come along today um it's just wonderful
to see the room full of people and it's
i haven't quite got a tear in my own eye
but i know how proud judy must feel
because like her i'm a secondary
master's teacher educator and yes i've
got generations of students as well but
i don't think i've ever seen
you know the generations of students in
one room like we have today so it's just
great and i'm really pleased that we are
able to use some of the the rudd gillard
rug
to gillard you and give you a lovely day
today
um and seeing the book is is really
interesting too actually we we published
the book at a time when i was um moving
on to a different job so coming face to
face with people who use the book is
rather exciting i have to say
um i'm really proud of it i know gloria
stillman and colleen vale my co-authors
are as well we're currently working on a
second edition
it's meant to be published by the middle
of this year but it won't be um we're
trying really hard and i have to tell
you the thing that i'm most proud of in
the book
is the cover
i really like the cover it's the only
color part because expensive to have and
when we were thinking about the cover
the the publisher said you know what
would you like to have on the cover and
i said no x's
no numbers no equal signs none of the
stereotypical stuff that people think
maths is about right none of that stuff
and then we thought no let's not have
photos of classrooms because whatever
you put on the cover first there's
ethics problems about having teachers
and kids but it shows one kind of
classroom that doesn't capture diversity
which is what i want to talk about today
and so i said i want something that
shows
mathematics in the world
you know in in nature and that was the
first picture that they sent along
and so i got it printed in color and i
walked up and down the corridor of my
building i'm the the only mass educator
there so i knocked on the doors of my
colleagues you know nothing about mass
education and said what do you think of
this and they went
ah
that's beautiful i thought right that's
it
so that's the story behind the cover
um so today
judy gave me a really broad brief so
what did she say current research and
implications for mathematics teaching
and learning i mean that's the entire
universe
so i got to pick what to talk about and
you can see the topic that i've chosen
up there today and the reason why i've
chosen this topic is because
in all my experience as a teacher
educator and someone who's worked with
pre-service teachers beginning teachers
and experienced teachers
this is what i found to be the greatest
challenge that people face
how to respond effectively to student
diversity and i found this on a bunch of
google images you just sort of type in
diversity and you get all these pretty
pictures so that's the kind of diversity
i'm talking about there so think about
the kinds of diversity that you're
facing
every day in your schools for those of
you who've taught in more than one
school if you've taught in really
different schools
i mean that's one aspect of diversity
and the location of the schools
even within a school if you're teaching
multiple math classes they're really
different i hope they are they're pretty
boring they're all the same
and even just within a class
there will be a great diversity of
students in a whole lot of different
ways
things like
gender
teaching boys versus teaching girls
versus teaching boys and girls together
social economic status
language cultural background students
prior mathematical achievement all those
things are different
so one of the really um privileged
things that you get to do when you give
a talk like this is that
you've got a license to provoke thinking
so that's what i want to do today to
provoke some thinking for you
and maybe challenge you challenge some
taken for granted practices things that
you might be doing not even aware of why
you're doing them that could be
unwittingly disadvantaging some students
so i want to promote thinking
and challenging today because that's
what learning is all about
so here's the plan
um all right responding to diversity
this is important so let's have a look
at the curriculum and see what that says
can we find some help there about how to
respond to diversity
and then i'm going to look at
research
particularly research that's been done
in australia recently about responding
to diversity
and i'm going to end up with a practical
example and christopher pine would love
that because this entire review of
teacher education all he wants is
practical stuff
all right now it's practice it's
practical stuff's good but it's got to
be informed by
the search i hope so i'm going to tell
you about some work that a group of
teachers that i've worked with a couple
of years ago are doing to respond to
diversity
but first before i do that
um i need to deal with the question of
why should we care
about responding to student diversity
and mathematics
and what does equity have to do about it
because i've got equity in the title
there
and so
here's one big reason why we should care
and i'm glad that was fabulous what
genie did is sort of taking you through
all the stuff that's happening in maths
education at the moment
all right let's have a look at pisa
so p is a program for international
student assessment
it's this big oecd funded international
comparison
tests
15 year old students in lots of
countries around the world it's been
going for many years it's done every
three years australia is one of the
countries that's participated every time
we've had it
the last pisa was conducted in 2012 and
the results were released with much
breathless fanfare in the beginning of
december last year in fact in the united
states they called it pisa day
they were just waiting for the results
to come out
and of course the media was full of it
so
what you end up with there's a whole lot
of data very interesting data
but what the newspapers are interested
in is the mean score so pisa tests three
things mathematics literacy science they
perceive reading literacy let's just
look at mathematics literacy
so the last result was overall
15 000 students in australia
the mean score was 504 504 watts well
never mind but
it was higher than the oecd average and
the difference was statistically
significant that's really important you
will never find those words in a
newspaper
never
of course having numbers like this
allows the results to be reported as a
league table like the olympic games the
gold medal table right this is what
governments are really interested in
because they want to know where does our
country stand in the league table
now it turned out in 2012 that there
were 16 countries above australia
never mind that there was no
statistically significant difference
between the schools of those countries
but australia was ranked
you know further down than we had been
in the past terrible terrible we're
slipping down the south
um
the international studies like this are
really interesting really useful there
are a lot of problems in making
comparisons between countries because of
cultural differences in the way
education works
but it's very interesting to look at the
data within a country
because it can be disaggregated in
different ways and this is where i think
we really need to pay some attention
because there are some trends here that
are not going away and they're not
getting any better this is why equity
matters here is the big picture for you
so i'm looking at the difference in
performance between certain groups of 15
year old students in australia
and all of these differences are
they're real they're statistically
significant so the way i've drawn this
graph is rather interesting because i'm
trying to make a point here
so i have set the x-axis
at the oecd mean of 504
and then i'm looking at performance
differences
between
most advantage and least advantage
groups arrange
across a whole range of variables here
so you can see um that the most
advantaged groups scoring above the mean
and the least advantage scripts below
the mean so let's look at gender
the change column is boys
they're doing all right just above the
mean right and column is girls below me
it doesn't look like much of a
difference but it's persistent it's
statistically significant
and it hasn't changed for the last three
pieces
in fact if anything it's getting worse
and you can equate the differences to
progress through a school year it's very
clever so boys are a third of the school
year ahead 15 year old boys
and it's not changing
the next group indigeneity
non-indigenous students
slightly above the mean indigenous
students way below me
and the difference is equivalent to two
and a half school years
15 year olds
location makes a difference to
performance as well
so there's three groups of schools here
metropolitan provincial and remote
all the pairwise differences are
statistically
significant 15 year olds in metropolitan
schools are three-quarters of a year
ahead of students in provincial schools
students in provincial schools are one
and a quarter years ahead of students in
remote schools
how can this be how does this make you
feel that where you go to school
seems to make a difference to your
mathematical performance
and then the last one socioeconomic
status
this compares the scores of students in
the highest quartile for ses with
students in the lowest quartile
huge differences again two and a half
school years
so your socio-economic status makes a
difference to your mathematical
performance
is not the only country that has these
differences but there are countries in
the world that don't have these kinds of
differences and that should give us
cause for hope
but this i think is why equity matters
this is why we need to care and pay
attention to responding to student
diversity
so
back to my questions
where can we go um to find out what we
can do to try and deal with this well
let's have a look at the curriculum the
australian curriculum mathematics
and i've gone i like to take people back
to the beginnings of the australian
curriculum
to the shape paper
which was written by one of our good
colleagues peter sullivan
and
i think there is fabulous stuff in the
shade paper which has kind of got washed
out a bit a lot in the curriculum so we
need to keep coming back to this there
are some strong statements here
so it's saying an unintended effect of
current practice has been to exclude
some students from future mathematics
study and i hope you're thinking oh
what current practice is doing that
the goal of equity of outcome is central
to the construct of the mathematics
curriculum
this includes consideration of the need
to engage more students as judy was
saying students are running away from
mathematics the way particular groups
have been excluded and the challenge
posed by creating
opportunity
so how can we create opportunity for all
students to engage productively with
mathematics
the shape paper goes on
to say and in looking at those those
differences between students and
different socio-economic status groups
in peace it's tempting to cater for this
spread of achievement by differentiating
opportunities
but it's essential that all students
have the opportunity to make progress
before and or during during the senior
secondary years where they get to choose
different types of math subjects
so the key first step is to affirm a
commitment to ensuring that all students
experience the full mathematics
curriculum until the end of year 10 with
schools developing relevant options that
preserve for all students a possibility
furthermore study
so differentiating opportunities
having different types of subjects
different groupings of students who are
undertaking a different curriculum
is something which is not seen to be
equitable
now if we fast forward to the current
version of the australian curriculum up
to version six already can you believe
it because i just checked the other day
um because i wanted to see what is it
what is it saying there about responding
to diversity and yes there's a section
there about that
and it says in the curriculum all
students this is after 10 are entitled
to rigorous relevant and engaging
learning programs drawn from the
australian curriculum mathematics and
teachers that's you
take account of the range of their
students current levels of learning
their strengths their goals their
interests and make adjustments when
necessary
okay
make adjustments
how do we do that
um
so there is some advice there this is
where i'm going to stop for a minute
because yes i've been talking for 15
minutes um and it's time for you to have
a talk to your neighbour so not yet i
need to tell you what to talk about
it's not just free people so i want you
to think about a math class that you
teach
and think of two students in your class
who are really different so they
exemplify some kind of diversity look it
might be a boy and a girl
it could be someone who's struggling
versus someone who's coping really well
it could be someone who has english as
their first language versus someone who
doesn't
there'll be students from different
cultural backgrounds all right you've
all got diversity in your classroom so
think of those two students and i want
you to talk to your neighbour about tell
them about these students
and
what are you doing to try and
take account of that diversity to help
those students to learn mathematics well
i'll give you a minute to have a talk
about that
all right you've all partnered really
well
that's the hardest thing to do you know
you let people talk and then you've got
to stop them from talking
but that's good because i wanted you to
be able to share some experience here
so you've all got obviously
something to talk about in relation to
diversity
let me continue um
looking at
your new south wales syllabuses your
board of study syllabuses that are
written for the australian curriculum
because i wanted to know i thought gee
i'm going to sydney i better find out
what your own syllabus is say about this
because you've got your own syllabuses
haven't you right
um
and yes your syllabuses do provide
general advice on uh responding to
diversity in terms of differentiated
programs so i went to the math syllabus
and there's a link there that goes to a
site about differentiated programming
but it's the same is there's just the
one
set of advice there for all subjects
so it talks about differentiation not
the calculus kind but differentiation is
a targeted process that involves board
planning programming and instruction
okay
and differentiated programming involves
teaching learning assessment the
learning experiences that cater for the
diversity of learners so all students
can learn effectively well that's that's
nice
lovely motherhood statements lovely
um but there's more there in fact there
are several pages of strategies
that can be used to differentiate
programming
so things like offering a range of
stimulus materials promoting flexible
learning experiment experiences
providing task centres and problem
solving opportunities
but i'm a maths teacher you know that
their strategies are not
math specific
now of course i'm sure that you're all
of you being well taught and well
trained and you'll be able to devise
strategies
but that's why
i want to take a step back now
and look at some mathematics specific
ways
of
differentiating programming or
responding to student diversity
and to do that i need to have a look at
research
mr pine
before we work out what to do we need to
know why
so
the research literature
talks about
three general approaches to respond to
student diversity i've summarized them
up there on the screen and i'm going to
talk about each of them in some more
depth
and
refer to some australian research and
then give you some examples
so the first and i think very common way
okay which will respond to student
diversity is what in australia we call
streaming
which typically involves sorting
students into different class groups
based on some kind of indicator of
ability usually a test of some kind and
usually
offering each class a different version
of the curriculum even though all the
classes might be studying a subject
called mathematics it may be that the
lower stream classes go more slowly
they might not go into topics in as much
depth and they'll leave out some topics
now this happens internationally as well
but it works in different ways and
there's different terminology used so if
you want to get into the literature here
you need to understand some of the
nuances
for example in the united states they
talk about tracking
rather than streaming in the united
kingdom they talk about setting rather
than streaming and there are some slight
differences there so um i just want to
tell you about a couple of different
ways of doing this you might not know
that in some countries
students are tracked into different
types of secondary schools
in germany for example there are some
academic secondary schools and there are
some technical secondary schools and the
exam that you do directs you into into
one of those
that we don't do that in australia but
that's what happens in germany in other
countries
tracking exists but within schools so in
singapore for example the secondary
curriculum has an express track that
like trains in it
so you get there really fast a normal
academic track and a normal technical
track again and students are set up in
those different directions based on
examination results
there's another kind of thing that
happens even in australia and you might
not have thought about this kind of
streaming but i'm going to throw it into
the mix because i've got a license to
provoke today
it's entirely common in australia to
have senior secondary mathematics
subjects not just one
right every state has three or four
subjects that offer different kinds of
mathematics which takes students in
different directions some towards
universities some never told this
university
so that's another way of differentiating
the curriculum that some students get to
do some subjects a subject but not
others
and then we've got the version that i've
just talked about here which is
essentially the same subject but we're
grouping students and offering them
different things
this is where i need to say
that what i've put up against number one
there
is not in keeping with the intent of the
australian curricular mathematics
it's certainly not the shape
so
let me just say
a little bit more about streaming so
what do we know about streaming there's
been a lot of research in this area in
fact there's been
30 years of research into
the effects of ability grouping in
mathematics all over the world so i've
just summarised some of the the findings
there so there's been lots of individual
studies
there's also been a lot of reviews of
research that synthesize the results
from many many many studies
so it otherwise it can be a bit hard
just looking at individual studies to
work out what they're saying so
one of the um
i guess the common rationale for
streaming and this is a noble rationale
because teachers are noble people and we
want the best for our students
the common rationale is a belief that
students have a certain kind of
mathematical ability and assigning
students to groups that correspond
to the measured level of ability or i'll
give them a test and know what they can
do and that makes it possible for us
then to tailor the content and to tailor
our teaching methods
to meet the differing needs of students
so that sounds like a way of responding
to diversity
and there is also a hope there i'm sure
that
by
working with the lower achieving
students separately that you'll be able
to help them catch up to their same age
peers
so if that's the goal of streaming then
it's really important for research to
ask
is that goal being achieved
all right here are some
some findings from lots and lots of
studies
now i hope the first point up there is
pretty uncontroversial because i'm sure
you know as teachers that there isn't a
single test or even group of tests that
can sort students into completely
homogeneous groups
all right you can sort and sort and sort
and sort but they're always going to be
different in some kind of way the only
way to have a completely homogeneous
class is to have a class of one
and that's not going to happen is it
all right there's always going to be
something reason there
now another thing that can happen
of course you know we all like to think
well you know if students improve then
it's possible for you to move to a
different group
but the evidence doesn't necessarily
suggest that
usually it's difficult for students to
move between groups because they might
have missed some topics they haven't
studied topics in enough depth so moving
to another group is going to leave them
still behind
so students can feel stuck
and that closes off future options
the third point there there is an
enormous amount of research
showing something really disturbing
that this practice can create
low expectations in us
teachers
this is debt
this is terrible
because we know and can research that
our expectations of students
strongly influence what we do in the
classroom
and it's it's not the expectations that
create student achievement that's magic
no
it's what we do that influences student
achievement so we must avoid low
expectations of students and it creates
a social stigma for lower strength
students they know
they know what cluster
they know how they will label themselves
we don't have to do that
the second last document is also really
important so does does this practice
what effect does it have on achievement
now if you're looking at the achievement
of the higher strings there are mixed
results there
some studies show that there are small
benefits for higher achieving students
and being streamed out into high
achieving groups other studies show
there is no benefit
but the constant message there for the
lowest stream students is that it
doesn't improve their achievement at all
and so this practice just reinforces
differences and in some cases increases
the differences between high and low
stream groups of students
so ultimately what it can do then is to
again contradict what we're trying to
achieve in terms of the shape paper is
denying low achieving students access to
the really good stuff
you know the stuff that might help them
feel challenged and interested and
wanting to keep on going in math so that
we don't have students dropping out of
the hard maths and seconds
so that's the overall farmers
internationally now let me really bring
this close to home because i'd like to
share with you some findings of some
recent australian studies couldn't find
any in new south wales
um it's interesting because it's really
hard to get data about the prevalence of
streaming in australia because people
don't collect data about that kind of
thing
i wonder why
so here's a recent study carried out by
a good colleague of mine hillary
foregaze who works at monash university
in victoria
and yes i know that i know they're over
the border but it's not that different
right from new south wales it's all part
of australia
so she was interested in teacher
receptions of streaming practices in
lower secondary mathematics so she
designed a survey for that send it to
all the schools in victoria there were
44 schools that responded that doesn't
sound like much but it represents a lot
of teachers
and they were very representative of
location school sector socio-economic
status and so on
and teachers reported there that
those teachers those schools streaming
was used in 80 of schools
now i was really tempted to ask you the
same question but i'm not going to put
you on the spot so this is victoria i
suspect the same would be happening in
queensland as well
interestingly the prevalence of
having different groupings of students
increased from year 7 up to year 10
and the reason for that and this is very
common is to have separate year 10
classes that kind of get ready get
students ready to go off into the
different senior subjects
so the people were asked do you support
your school streaming practices and most
people said yes
and they were asked why
and they said because we think it caters
to the needs of students with differing
abilities
so there's the noble goal which research
suggests isn't necessarily being
achieved
she also asked them well how are
students selected to go into the
different streams the most common
criteria were based on
grades and marks exam results and
teacher recommendations
another question she asked was do you
think streaming benefits all students
yes or no
and
why
and there were mixed results there about
two-thirds of the teachers said yes i
think it does
but one-third
said no
i'm fairly certain that it doesn't and i
just want to share with you some of the
the comments that those teachers said
one teacher said once the stream's been
running for a few weeks the differences
become a gulf
preventing students from changing to
more appropriate streams
we all say it can be done but really
it's too hard isn't that terrible that
the administrative structures kind of
get in the way of what we know is good
for kids and what we would like to do
for kids
timetables school timetables are
terrible things
terrible things
another teacher said
lower ability students do not benefit by
being greek with students of similar
abilities so they're missing out on that
experience of interacting with students
who have a deeper understanding of maths
goes on to say even though it's a
student's choice they label themselves
as being in veggie maths don't you hate
that too
isn't that sad
the teacher also observed something else
that's interesting generally the better
maths teachers are allocated to this is
the highest stream year 10 class so
something going on there about the best
qualified teachers get to teach the
higher achieving kids
and the teachers who are teaching out of
field get assigned to the other groups
so there's that kind of differentiation
going on as well that's a tragedy and we
know there's this shortage of qualified
nurse teachers in australia see how
complicated the problem is
this is a really complex problem
which is not going to be easy to solve
another australian study by another good
colleague robert zevenbergen now robin
jorgensen
was looking at uh streaming in
queensland and she was interested in
student perceptions of their experiences
in class
in particular
what kind of mathematical identity did
they have all of you have a mathematical
identity and i suspect it's really
strong
you know you you feel strong in
mathematics you know it's useful and
it's beautiful and you feel competent
and confident
but how did these students feel
so they're in years nine and ten
and not surprisingly she found that
students in the high streams
they felt pretty good about themselves
as doers and mathematics and they
thought maths was a useful useful thing
to know
whereas students in the lower streams
had quite quite different experiences
they talked about teachers having
negative beliefs about their abilities
they felt frustrated about being stuck
in this lower class didn't matter how
hard they worked they felt
they knew they couldn't get out and not
surprisingly what do students do when
they're feeling bored and frustrated
they find ways of entertaining
themselves
bad behaviour
students deliberately choose to behave
badly like that
because they're not getting anything
useful they don't want to be there and
they'd much rather be out of the class
not a very pleasant experience for the
student or the teacher
so let me just show you some of the
things that these these young people
said
they were very finely attuned to what
they thought their teachers believed
about them
so a year nine boy i don't like being in
this class it's because it's the only
one i feel dumb in
english a workshop i'm doing okay but in
maths i feel like a [ __ ]
teacher treats us as if we know nothing
and then a year nine girls it's like
they say you are smart and you are done
and then put us in classes where they
make sure it happens
self-fulfilling prophecy
um
and in fact robin claims this is a
very challenging confronting thing which
he claims that streaming does more than
respond to diversity of the noble goal
it can actually
create
differences in achievement by the kind
of
practices that these students are
referring to
um
here's one poor united girl i get so
annoyed in this because i want to get
out of this class teacher doesn't really
care about us the boys all muck around
and we get no work done
i've worked really hard even got a home
tutor to help me
but we aren't doing the hard stuff so i
don't know the work on the exam
all right the other classes get to do
the hard stuff we get you know a
slimmer diet
water down freaking i want to get into a
better class but i just can't so this
raises another thing that the good
intentions of trying to go a little bit
more slowly
helping students experience some success
in mathematics we know how important
that is
but it can turn around and bite us if
we're not careful because it means we're
leaving stuff out
and mathematics is a progressive
sequential hierarchical subject it's
very hard to catch up later
um and this is my favorite i think this
is a year 10 point i'm in the dummies
class
it's really boring in there so i'll see
it as my job to make of fun me my mates
have set the teacher up he's got a short
fuse so it doesn't take long
i get sent off to the thinking room
at least that's better than that
and kids do this all the time
all the time you know that
it's quite deliberate it's not
accidental you know they're
up in the thinking room
um pretending to be it just doesn't
happen
so
all right i've scared you now haven't i
so streaming has all these dreadful
negative consequences what are the
alternatives
what do we need to do all right we're
all caring people we're all well
qualified you know we want our students
to to do what are the alternatives all
right let me go back to um the two other
things that were in my list
one thing that you can do to
differentiate the curriculum is by
offering different tasks to students in
your class
so
you're not
separating students into different
groups
you've got a heterogeneous class but
you're designing different kinds of
tasks and this is pretty much the kind
of advice that you'll find on the border
studies website about differentiating
programs
and there's a range of strategies you
can try things called tiered instruction
where you've got sort of hierarchical
set of activities that vary in
complexity
some people use individual contracts
with
independent research projects
i can't imagine doing that for an entire
year because you'll be burned out and we
don't want you to be burned out maybe
once a year you could do that
prepared or small group work where you
the teacher can can offer different
types of instruction to those groups
the thing that still worries me about
that
is that there still might be some
disadvantage there for the struggling
students if you're separating them from
the rest of the class
and if you're not allowing them to
access the really rich motivating hard
tasks
but how can that work
how can you make that work how can you
engage students with with those richer
kinds of tasks well this is where i'm
going to draw on the work of another set
of good australian colleagues peter
sullivan who i mentioned before zebedee
bergen whom i mentioned before and judy
mostly who was at deakin university and
they did a wonderful project not very
long ago
but tackled this this real conundrum of
how can we respond to student diversity
when we've got you know mixed mixed
group in front of us some kids are
flying some are struggling
how we're going to help them all learn
so
they proposed that the best way to do
this
is in your lesson design
so you can start by designing
a set of tasks but all students all
students get to work on the same tasks
so a series of tasks which might begin
with some closed tasks
but end with
an open-ended
task
so you're teaching the students as you
go along with the closed house to make
sure they gain the necessary experience
so they can all
access the bigger open task at the end
not in the same way and they won't do it
end up in the same points
but the interesting point that they made
about this was that tasks alone
don't constitute a differentiated
curriculum
because what really matters is what you
the teacher do
to intervene to help your students
engage with those tasks now to me i find
that a really um
positive and uplifting message because
it highlights that you matter
what you do in the classroom is the most
important thing that makes a difference
to student achievement so i hope that
makes you feel yeah
you know i can do this
what they talked about then so what do
you do to intervene help students engage
with the task that at first blush you
think god they're never going to be able
to do this
they talked about two different types of
prompts
one type they called enabling prompts
these are the kind of prompts that you
can use to help
get kids over barriers that might be in
their way if they're trying to get
towards engaging with an interesting
task
it could be little calculation problems
it could be little gaps in their
knowledge so their argument is why would
you allow that barrier to stay there
and not never allow the student to jump
over and see the beautiful mathematics
on the other side
so there's a range of things that you
can do to help students over barriers
i'll show you some examples in a moment
and i think all of you are doing this
right now in your classrooms but you
just don't know
so i'm giving it a label for you
now the other thing that can happen is
of course you're always going to have
kids who will zoom through the task
they'll finish early gee what am i going
to do with them
so what do you do do you seem to do the
textbook and say do another 100 practice
exercises
practice is good but
what um
peter sullivan and his colleagues are
saying is you can devise extending price
let's keep them engaged with the task
but extend their thinking make them go
deeper extend the task in interesting
and productive ways
so this is where i need to tell you how
do you do this what does this actually
look like in a real classroom
let me just give you some examples of
enabling prompts that they've suggested
you're doing this right now i'm sure
things like
you could make a problem
simpler to help the student progress
through it by reducing the number of
steps
you can
draw a diagram you can reduce the number
of variables
you can simplify the mode of
representing results that's a lot of big
words if you've got a task where
students have to record something
they're collecting data or they're
measuring something there are some
students you can just say go out and do
it and they'll work out how to record
these
but some students need a bit of
prompting a bit of scaffolding and for
those students you might need to re to
provide them with a reported recording
format
reduce the written elements kids don't
like writing
do you united states
they write in english they come into
your math classroom and suddenly go all
helpless and don't want to write
anything so
there might be other ways that you can
help them record things
of course you know ways of making
problems more concrete using smaller
numbers simplifying the language and so
on
okay so there's some types of enabling
prompts
and i'll illustrate
both of those types of prompts i'm going
to show you i'm just looking at the time
yes i've got time to show you both these
things this is what i'm now going to um
tell you about in this project i did a
couple of years ago in 2011 and 2012
and i was invited to do this by the
independent schools association of
queensland
and the project was about
differentiating the curriculum in junior
secondary mathematics
and the reason why
i was asked to do it at that time was
because the australian curriculum
mathematics had just been launched
and it says you've got to teach all of
all the maths right up to year 10
and so you know teachers were thinking
like you are now how am i going to do
that when i've got so many diverse
students in my class what's a good way
of doing this
so um i worked with another colleague
shelley dole working with these teachers
in about 30 schools over two years now
when i say independent schools let me
explain the kind of schools i was
working with they were very diverse
themselves
they ranged from
some
brisbane schools that were very
old
and lit and academically oriented
through to some very new independent
schools in
provincial towns in regional parts of
queensland which were not well
resourceful
um low fee schools
and were not resourced well in another
important way and again this links back
to something judy was saying before
some of the schools we worked in didn't
have any qualified mathematics teachers
none at all
right some of them were primary trained
some of them were trained to teach other
subjects but they came along because
they wanted to find out better ways of
helping their students
so we work with those teachers um over a
couple of years
so we had to demonstrate some ways of
how do you do this you know
with prompt extending prompt stuff what
does it look like in a real classroom
and so i decided to bring with me one of
my good friends
i'm fascinated by barbie yeah
i really am i've had a barbie doll when
i was growing up i've got one now um i
bought one i claimed it as a tax
deduction had to explain to my
accountant
and i collect newspaper clippings about
barbie and her wardrobe and her
occupations and the way she's gender
stereotyping and you know causing little
girls to have completely wrong
impressions about the way they should
look
so i've sort of devised a series of
activities around those two questions
is barbie for real you know is she a
realistic representation of human
proportions i've been seeing the maths
in this for a proportional reason and
what would she look like
if we scaled her up to my heart
for example
so i hope there's images forming in your
mind how would you do this with the
class of young adolescents yes we
measure we measure ourselves when
there's a barbie but we never measure
parts of us that are embarrassing
we measure things like head
circumference length of our nose index
finger and so on
and do interesting things there but i
don't have time to go into detail about
it today but just let me talk about that
second question that's a very open
question isn't it what would she look
like if we scaled her up to human heart
all right let me give you some enabling
prompts
here's one
i'm fascinated by her tiny little waist
have you ever noticed her lace is really
small
so let's just look at her waist
measurement
i wonder what that would be if we scaled
her up to my heart
now i don't care to tell you what my
waist measurement is i don't have to
i'm going to do this in a different way
so um how could we work out what her
waist measurement would be if we scaled
her up to my height
does the word scale help you there
we could use barbie's height
barbie dolls is 30 centimeters high
um and if you measure my height i'm
about five and a half times
the height of barbie so five and a half
times oh now we need something else okay
so she's yes i'm five and a half times
that's the scale factor now barbie's
waist is a very smelt nine centimeters
it's quite hard to get a tape measure
around there but you can't need this
string
all right so that's a good thing about
measuring nine centimeters
so if we assume
we're making some assumptions here that
all of barbie would be scaled up by five
and a half then you've got to multiply
nine by five and a half
and you get
49.5 centimeters
so what does 49 and a half centimeters
look like well i haven't got a tape
measure with me
um how can i compare it oh i know
every year i go to graduation ceremonies
didn't see the lovely photo of judy at a
graduation ceremony wearing you know
when you've got a phd you get to wear
this lovely bonnet
and so you know you go i don't have my
own um my own down and rows you go and
get them for free
as an academic and you've got to tell
them your head circumference so i happen
to know my head circumference
it's i think it's 57 centimeters
would we say barbie's waist box
49 and a half so she was my height her
waist would be smaller than my head
circumference
so you know what i do with the tape
measure it comes
not very far
around my waist
all right so
i've just given you a series of enabling
prompts to help you tackle this
open-ended task um
and i won't go into this but here are
some some interesting information that
i've collected about barbie over the
years i'm sure you'll find it very
interesting too
she used to be curvier
but in 1997 she was redesigned
some information at every second three
barbie dolls are sold summer as well
that's how much she's worth to mattel
she sent over a billion pairs of shoes
my husband complains he's actually told
me recently do you know you've got 24
pairs of shoes in your wardrobe
and i said
yes
that's a problem
so another thing that i did with the
teachers is to say well here's here's
some information can you design some
extending prompts that might help
students
take this investigation further for
example um
you could ask well given that
information how many dollars are sold
each year what's the average price of a
barbie doll based on that information
how does that compare with what you can
get them for down in kmart where i
bought my bubble
so that's some examples of extending
prompts and if you still think this has
nothing to do with maths let me tell you
that the first talking barbies said two
sentences
i love shopping
that class
is tough
all right talk about stereotypes
and that's a beautiful barbie that was
at cheney airport in singapore a few
years ago
all right so that's what i mean by
enabling an extending class that could
help engage all students
then the teachers had to go away and try
stuff themselves
and it was hard so i'll show you
what this bunch of teachers from um
thunderbird christian college came up
with at the end of their two years
now i know that's a bit hard to see so
i'm going to talk to you about it why
have i chosen them
a lot of reasons
when i first met these teachers it was
in february 2011.
one month earlier
queensland had been devastated by
terrible floods
a third of the state was under water you
might have only seen pictures of
brisbane but thunderbird was just washed
away
the school was really badly damaged
there were hundreds of people who lost
their homes
so
the flood washed away all the topsoil
from the school's oval which isn't oval
shaped as you can see but
so they devised a project the teachers
to get the kids to work out how much
would it cost to top dress the oval
if you top dress it with 50 millimeters
of new soil and top dressing costs so
much per cubic meter this was real yeah
the school had to this is the poor
school were they going to be able to do
this or not so they designed this
project and wanted the kids to take two
approaches the first approach was isn't
google google earth wonderful all right
there's the school that's the satellite
image you can't see it down the corner
but there's a scale there
that says this far is 50 meters
that was the task
open is that but they anticipated in
their work solution here a whole series
of enabling prompts little bits of help
they might be able to give the kids
like um
this is an irregular shape here is a way
of dividing it into regular shapes
telling them what the scale factor was
instead of asking them to work it out i
think a lot of the art of good teaching
is the art of anticipation of what kids
are going to do so they anticipated this
stuff
the second way in which the kids had to
do it was to get a trundle wheel and go
outside
do some real-life measuring and again
there's a whole set of enabling fronts
here that the teachers had anticipated
where the students might need some more
help
and it turned out in the work solutions
that they had when you work out the cost
using the satellite image it's over 26
000 you could use them trundle wheels
about 24 000.
here are some of the extending prompts
they came up with
what if the school can only allocate 10
000
to the cost of repairs
how does that affect the depth
so you worked it out for 50 millimeters
you know what what could you afford to
put on for ten thousand dollars and is
it worth doing
a really nice second extending prompt is
essentially saying generalize
create a general model for working this
out
and then the third one all right you've
done it two ways
um
which method do you think is the best
method
and why
would you think that
so
that's just an example of how they
designed a quite a big a big task that
thought about ways in which they could
help all those diverse students get
through it and extend the ones who
finished early and they had a huge range
of achievement levels in this school it
was really worrying the teachers the
other thing that they why they joined
the project was that most of the kids
hated maths
they hated it they didn't want to do it
so they were trying to devise some
mathematical activities that were real
for the students as well
all right that's how i've tried to
answer those questions but let me just
come to a final word
differentiating the curriculum in the
way that i've just described is hard
this is not an easy thing for us to do
because it requires significant teacher
knowledge and skills
and time peace
so just think about the demands on you
you are qualified teachers what about
those teachers at bungalow
who didn't have the advantages that you
had of being taught on june apps
so it's hard but i think there are at
least two reasons why it's important
that we as a nation rise to this
challenge the first one goes back to the
equity considerations that i mentioned
at the start i find it completely
unacceptable that
diversity is associated with different
levels of mathematical achievement i
think that's a lot on our country the
second reason again as judy mentioned at
the start i didn't know what she was
going to say it was wonderful
but we
teacher educators and teachers are under
intense
pressure and scrutiny to justify our
professional status and our professional
practice
leon talked about the project that we're
doing with money that came from the
previous government it was the chief
scientist who instigated that because
he's been highly critical of the quality
of maths and science teaching and
learning in australian schools
you know you see politicians you see the
media commentators constantly
criticizing us
and what we do and yes
christopher pines inquiry into teacher
education the issues paper came out last
week
and somehow we have to respond to this
thing
so i think we can respond in a couple of
important ways firstly we all need to be
advocates for our profession
the profession of teaching uh being
teacher educators and especially in
mathematics education
because we are not well understood by
people out there maybe it's because
we're not very good at telling people
what it is that we do and all the good
stuff that we do we need to get better
at talking to people who are not like us
we're good at talking to people who are
like us
but somehow we've got to get better at
talking to those people who want to
criticize us
second thing i think and we need to be
very honest about this is that whenever
there is an inquiry
it does provide an opportunity for us to
reflect on
the quality of our own knowledge and the
quality of our own practice and if
necessary to seek new knowledge
and new practices and to constantly look
for improvement because that is the one
of the hallmarks of a professional
and so the question i'll leave you with
to think about today is how well
prepared do you feel to respond to
student diversity in ways that create
opportunity and equitable outcomes and
how are you going to go about becoming
better prepared for that
so thank you again for the opportunity
and i hope you have a wonderful day